I think what inspires me is a mix of
the unknown
and the excitement of something new.
My research focus falls in
the back-and-forth between
digital and physical. Looking into how
physiological information and like brain
signals electrodermal activity and any
type of physiological sensor can be used
to allow us to express in the digital
world our needs that we have.
A lot of my work uses Dakota
motifs and symbols to
show the philosophy of how we as Dakota people approach the world.
Since coming to MIT,
I've had opportunities to learn
new technologies. I created a piece
specifically for this show that is a
sound vessel. And it's a clay vessel that
actually transmits sound.
My work is mostly oil painting.
One of the things
I've shown here
is my subway series.
It's just basically a series of
snapshots of scenes from my everyday
commute on the Red Line. Mostly
interested in that intersection of these
personal moments within a very public
space, and kind of
how they interfere with each other.
I view my work as a
socio-technical synthesis.
I'm using geometry and
exploring geometry with the
human body and also trying to evoke
some emotion and sort of Gestalt shifts to
how we actually view reality.